[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight for the past 18 months
Democrats in the Congress and they are
PR consultants in the press have told
you that Donald Trump won the 2016
presidential election mostly because his
campaign somehow colluded with the
government of Vladimir Putin to prove
that they have brought the usual
business of government here in
Washington basically to a standstill and
launched the most divisive Special
Counsel investigation in the history of
the country it has now going on for more
than a year and yet remarkably to this
very day we still have no proof of
collusion just this weekend Democrat
Mark Warner of the Senate Intel
committee who was someone everybody in
Washington pretends is impressive was
offered a chance on television to
provide actual evidence of Russian
collusion he declined of course he did
they always do you've seen this before
but tonight we have something different
for you we have a Democrat who says he
has the smoking gun three months ago we
made this offer to congressman Eric SWA
wall of California who is a member of
the House Intelligence Committee watch
if you have any evidence at all of
clusion any and I don't care how small
it is I will give the floor to you and I
mean that because I just I want to wrap
this up I'm sure you do too so with the
offered the congressman a full half-hour
live on this show if he could give us
evidence real evidence of Russian
collusion by Trump's campaign and his
credit tonight he is taking us up on
that offer
there is nothing staged about this
conversation the one you're about to see
if the congressman has proof that Trump
people colluded with a hostile foreign
power we will be the first to call for
indictments but if he doesn't have that
proof if after all this time there are
still no real evidence of collusion then
we will know for certain that this whole
thing is a lie that has badly damaged
our country we're gonna find out in just
a minute
meanwhile the Russia investigation
continues to expose deep and terrifying
corruption in Washington and not in the
ways the people who launched it expected
on Friday the New York Times and The
Washington Post reported that the Obama
administration employed a spy who posed
as an advisor to the Trump campaign
during the 2016 election he was a
longtime CIA asset who fed information
back to federal intelligence agencies
the Obama people lied about doing this
but they did it as far as we know
nothing like that has ever happened in
American history Richard Nixon was
accused of less than that and he left
office so you'd think the self-described
guardians of democracy in the media
would be horrified by the suggestion of
partisan spying no matter what they
think of Trump personally but they're
not horrified instead they're
aggressively defending it like the
Craven lackeys they are the Washington
Post over the weekend actually ran an
op-ed with this headline we're not
making this up quote the FBI didn't use
an informant to go after Trump they used
one to protect him amazingly the New
York Times agreed with that here was its
story in the subject quote FBI used
informant to investigate Russia ties to
campaign not to spy in other words
Donald Trump should be grateful that
Obama's FBI spied on him it was for his
own good the people who wrote this crap
should be ashamed it's not journalism
it's partisan cheerleading it's also
embarrassingly credulous just transcribe
whatever spin you got from your FBI
source and call it a news story
now with these idiot reporters feel if
the Trump administrate
read their emails or tap their
cellphones or sent a spy to spy on them
and then claimed it was all for their
own good well obviously they'd be
outraged and so would we because we're
not hacks Obama's CIA director John
Brennan by contrast is a hack he's also
a liar who's done more to embarrass and
discredit the so called intelligence
community than any other single person
Brennan has been on Twitter attacking
Trump and anyone else who wants to know
more about the Obama administration's
spying efforts in the last campaign as
if Americans don't have a right to know
when their government is spying on them
and why a ruling class is completely out
of control that's the real lesson this
Russian nonsense and if the latest
details were joined by Byron New York of
the Washington Examiner and George
Washington University Law Professor
Jonathan Turley professor first to you
does the public do Americans have a
right to know if they were spied on and
why I think that they do I mean these
are very serious allegations and they
are unprecedented you know we don't know
what the truth is maybe there was a
valid reason for the investigation maybe
they use valid means but we should want
to know I mean what what I think is
being a case of willful blindness here
is that we have confirmation that Trump
apparently was correct when he said over
a year ago that he had people in his
campaign they were under surveillance
and it turns out that it was much
broader than we thought
even though people like clapper and
others in the Obama administration
denied it it does appear to be a
surveillance program it does appear to
be an investigation
and now you have an individual who
reportedly offered to be an adviser in a
campaign when he was an asset for the
FBI or the CIA or both I can't imagine
what justice official would sign off on
that no you can't you know try to split
this as you may whether there is this is
an investigation or surveillance but
from Trump's standpoint there's a
legitimate issue you can tell a victim
that you know this isn't a mugging it's
just a forced divestiture but it sure
feels like a mugging unless you can
prove to the contrary if Bush had done
this to Obama I would want to know why
and I think it's fair to want to know so
what do we know Byron you've been
reporting on this
did this start well the emergence of
this informant has kind of thrown into
doubt our previous timetable of this
remember we've always been told that the
FBI investigation formally started on
July 31st they wrote up something called
the electronic communication it started
this investigation but now we hear that
the informant was actually reaching out
and talking to Trump campaign campaign
people well before that at least weeks
before that maybe longer before that and
I think what you're seeing on Capitol
Hill is some investigators Republican
investigators are looking even further
back than that so what would that mean
that he was doing it you know laterally
because he was interested or that he was
doing at the direction of one of the
Obama agencies well he that he was doing
it at the direction of an agency before
they had a pretense a pretext to
actually do this so that that would be a
big issue inside the FBI also we're
seeing some investigators looking even
further back to March on March 24th
first Trump goes to the Washington Post
meets with their editorial board
remember he was under a lot of ember
very well under a lot of criticism for
not having a group of foreign policy
advisers in part because the entire
Republican foreign policy establishment
had shunned him and they asked him well
who are your advisers he pulls a piece
of paper out of his pockets well here
they are and he reads off a list and on
the list are Carter page and George
papadopolis and we know now that James
Comey and Andrew McCabe personally
briefed the Attorney General Loretta
Lynch about them back then that's in
March and then shortly thereafter they
were discussed at what's called the
National Security Council principles
committee which is secretaries of state
treasury defense CIA all these people
are talking about Carter page then
totally shocking professor quickly since
you've got more historical perspective
on this than most people is this without
precedent if true has anything like this
ever happened I know I know of no
precedent to support this now they have
a case to make the point though is for
those people that are objecting what are
you objecting to I mean this is a
serious matter no matter how you feel
about Trump we need to find out the
truth
about this if there was an investigation
of an opposing political party if there
was an asset who tried to become an
advisor in the campaign those were a
serious matters for all of us and I
think the Trump is right he might have
got he went around bout it I think in
the wrong way but he has a legitimate
objection here that we should know the
true facts I agree and I don't think
it's about Trump at all thank you both
very much I appreciate it